based on the young adult book trilogy
about a dystopian America divided into
competitive sections this do--why
teenage heroine must lead a revolt
against a ruthless dictator who wait
guys we did this one already it's The
Hunger Games no John not The Hunger
Games
it's not are you sure because it looks
and sounds exactly like The Hunger Games
yeah there's no fight to the death on
this one so it's the same movie but
without the actual games that sounds
horrible divergent enter a world
inspired by a woman who read The Hunger
Games and said to herself I can change
that slightly and make a ton of money
journey to an overly complicated future
where every teenagers career is
determined by a test that places them
into one of five factions each based on
a single personality trait unless they
test positive for more than one which
makes them a divergent but it's
different from being factionist which
basically means you're homeless but the
test doesn't matter because they can
choose whatever affection they want
which leads to another series of tests
two stages of training we train
separately from the dauntless born but
you'll be ranked together after
initiations rankings will determine what
jobs you move into rankings will also
determine who gets cut the end of each
stage of training the lowest rank of the
bowl of names in the sorting ad were a
lot more straightforward Gryffindor
volunteer as tribute to one of five
factions each named after a different
SAT word there's abnegation the district
twelves erudite the slytherins Amity the
hufflepuffs the other one and dauntless
the cool faction that plays games gets
tattoos and does parkour that every team
would choose to join because no teenager
in their right mind would ever choose to
be a [ __ ] farmer me Tris a secretly
divergent advocate turned dauntless
who's just as insufferable as this
sentence she's a heroine you're not
embarrassed to like who's smarter than
Bella
and more decisive than Katniss but that
won't stop her from getting her ass
kicked a lot
witness a creepy romance bloom between
Tris and her much much older trainer
with an equally dumb name my name is 4/4
like the number and thrill as these
rebellious divergents uncover an evil
conspiracy to eradicate an entire
district I mean faction watch things
heat up as shailene woodley and this
superhot tattooed hunk make out while
fighting against miles teller who she
made out with in the spectacular now and
being related to Ansel Elgort who she
made out with in The Fault in Our Stars
yeesh it's like a Quarter Quell of guys
she leans porked sit back for a fill
full of things that are obvious attempts
to patter to teenage girls like staring
at yourself in the mirror having perfect
hair no matter how much you work out hot
older boys who see how special you are
on the inside and know exactly who you
are and telling them the choosing your
clique is the most important decision
you'll ever make
faction before blood so get ready to be
left hanging
while our two love interests outsmart
the evil government then ride off on a
tray into an uncertain future
guys I'm telling you we did this already
starring cat RIS I am Number Four The
Fault in Our co-stars kilometers teller
old Rose Makai five minutes of screen
time Kat Von D and Sina's daughter not
The Hunger Games
yikes one kid with hepatitis and they're
all going down be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers did you know we
make video game trailers too click here
to check out our epic honest trailer for
Pokemon and be sure to subscribe to
Smosh games what ain't no country I ever
heard of they speak English and what'd
you get nothing
you lose good day sir everybody do the
flop it's time we touched wands Harry
who lives in a pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants